I'm Tyler and I'm a disciple of more
time this is your at-home white eye full
body cardio workout ok guys so this is a
full body cardio workout my entire style
yeah so she rode me through a few of
these let's see what you got ok so what
we're gonna do is gonna be a double knee
strike ok so we're gonna practice our
upper and lower body in general so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna keep both my
hands to this position ok and this is
almost in general to where if I was
gonna be in front of somebody where I
could grab ahold of them so we're gonna
come down and kind of do a half squat
now when you do that make sure your
knees stay behind your toes a little bit
you're sticking your butt back you're
really feeling your butt your glutes
engaged you're gonna push and drive your
shoulders and you're gonna stand
straight up right then what I'm going to
do is I'm gonna bring my right knee up
point my toe down put that foot down
lefty will come up put that toe down
then I'm gonna take my left elbow left
elbow up right elbow up back to the half
squat knee knee elbow elbow now when you
drive your elbows up make sure that
you're being almost like you're sliding
your hands along your hairline okay
you're really using your elbows in your
hands to come up to actually cover your
face you're using it as a weapon to
throw your elbow up it hits the with a
chin but you're also using as a blocking
technique so you want to make sure you
keep those hands high and cover your
face ok your first rep should look like
your last rep everything should be
exactly perfect perfect reps equal
perfect body good now we're gonna go
ahead and drop right into this you're
gonna do a push-up whole - go ahead and
drop right down when we do this and I
don't want to drop and twist my hips
okay I want to keep my back straight but
what I'm gonna do is try to bring my
knees straight in okay touch the ground
just bring my knee in and go back it
squeeze in my leg and my oblique
squeezing the stomach the stomach tight
you're thirty of those
perfect remember Nina out to the side
because your hip doesn't really work
that way you want to try to bring that
knee right down the middle
good remember we don't want to explode
where you're driving the knee fourth try
to control it bring it in nice and slow
and squeeze if you feel that right sir
getting it foot and then look at this
what you're doing we have anybody touch
away okay so to recap guys we started
off with the knee knee elbow elbow first
going into that half squat very
important and then we finished off with
the push-up stance bringing your knees
slowly right down the line right there
and again you do those four solid minute
minute and a half to start as you build
strength and endurance you can just
increase that number right to whenever
so thanks guys that was your my time
full body cardio workout make sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
other fighting weight episodes
you